les vœux à Montigny-le-Bretonneux le
maire Michel Laugier vient de tenir sa
cérémonie et de vœux personnalité nous
allons revenir sur les principales
annonces lors de cette soirée avec
Anthony Reich bonsoir Anthony bonsoir
Wilfried alors comme chaque année ça se
déroulait à la Ferme du Manet une
cérémonie de vœux toute somme classique
quasiment tous les maires de la
communauté d'agglomération était présent
ainsi que François Demazières député de
la circonscription et forcément il a été
question lors de l'ensemble des
cérémonies de voeux d'un petit mot sur
la politique nationale oui on pouvait
pas y échapper les vœux ont commencé par
une petite tirade ironique du maire à
Michel yoger logier contre François
Hollande je cite je suis un maire normal
enfin presque normal ma cravate n'est
pas de travers mon épouse n'a pas de
compte Twitter et je ne change pas
d'avis en fonction de mes interlocuteurs
je crois que tout est dit voilà les vœux
c'est surtout l'occasion d'annoncer et
tout d'abord quelques quelques annonces
concernant les seniors deux grands deux
grands projets en 2013 tout d'abord le
relais des seniors qui devrait t'ouvrir
dans quelques mois ses portes il sera
ouvert à l'heure du déjeuner dans les
locaux de ancienne école Maurice
Genevoix dans le quartier du village
l'autre grand projet c'est la maison de
retraite constituée d'un EHPAD qui
devrait voir le jour dans le château de
La Coudre il serait constitué d'une
partie hébergement pour personnes âgées
dépendantes et d'une résidence service
la décision est alors actuelle entre les
mains du conseil général et de l'agence
régionale santé l'appel à projet a été
publié le 3 janvier un appel à projet
auquel a répondu évidemment la ville de
Montigny verdict au printemps et puis
une autre annoncelle ne fera sans doute
pas plaisir mais c'est habituel aux
habitants de Magny-les-Hameaux oui c'est
l'annonce concernant le CV7
le CV7 ne sera donc pas réouvert
contrairement à la à l'enquête qui avait
été menée il y a quelques semaines qui
proposait justement la réouverture aux
voitures en semaine dans le sens
Montigny Magny-les-Hameaux pour
poursuvenir ce chemin vicinal est fermé
la circulation depuis à peu près 10 ans
c'est la route qui est derrière la ferme
en fait du Manet en direction de la
vallée de Chevreuse on va s'intéresser
maintenant à plusieurs chantiers de 2013
oui il y a beaucoup de chantiers sur la
commune de Montigny en ce moment le
premier c'est l'arrivée de Mercedes non
dont on parlait depuis plusieurs mois
sur la commune ini Montaine la marque va
installer son son siège social dans le
quartier du pas du lac la première
pierre sera posée dans quelques jours et
puis l'autre grand chantier est un conçu
particulièrement atvfile c'est le vélo
de Drôme à 50 ans en Yvelines édifice
que l'on voit grandir jour après jour la
charpente vient d'être installée et la
couverture du toit devrait être
finalisée d'ici trois quatre semaines
l'ensemble sera livré le 13 décembre
prochain et devrait accueillir les
premiers championnats de France de
cyclisme sur piste début 2014 merci
Anthony pour ce point ce qu'il fallait
retenir des vœux du maire de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux la semaine
prochaine nous reviendrons sur les vœux
du maire UMP dès l'encours n'oubliez pas
que vous pouvez retrouver l'ensemble de
nos comptes rendus sur les vœux des
principaux élus du secteur sur notre
site internet TVfil 78 point